what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and with what seems to
be the official release date for
Spider-Man 4 in the MCU July 12th of
2024 and with recent reports about a new
Sony and Marvel Studio Disney deal for a
new Spider-Man contract almost being
complete fans have been wondering what
exactly is Spider-Man 4's plot going to
be about but Marvel Studios and
specifically Marvel Studios is President
Kevin feige has been kind of laying the
groundwork about what we should expect
to see in Spider-Man 4. however some
things might be a tad bit misleading let
me explain before we really dive into it
I'm sure the vast majority of the people
watching this video right now have seen
the post-credits scene for Venom Let
There Be Carnage where Tom Hardy's Venom
went to the MCU he then saw Tom Holland
Spider-Man on the TV now if you've seen
that post-credits scene I'm assuming you
have seen the post-credits scene for
Spider-Man no way home no not the
trailer for Doctor Strange 2 but the
post credit scene where Tom Hardy's
Venom then gets taken out of the MCU but
he leaves part of the Symbiote behind
seemingly setting up the next Spider-Man
movie to be about the Venom symbiote
however there have been some reports
from some insiders stating that that's
not going to be the case for Spider-Man
4 but Tom Holland's Spider-Man might
actually get the Venom symbiote in
Avengers Secret Wars if this is true
it's kind of cool because this is
actually what happens in the comics
Spider-Man gets the Venom symbiote the
black suit for the very first time in
secret Wars we'll talk about this more
in a bit but basically it doesn't look
like Spider-Man 4 is going to explore
the Symbiote too much however what it's
looking like it will explore is the
street level side of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and this has fans
super super excited and a big reason for
that is it looks like we are finally
going to see Spider-Man and Daredevil in
the same project According to some
Insider accounts online it looks like
Spider-Man no way home is going to pick
pick up after the events of Daredevil
born again there's even rumors that
Spider-Man could possibly appear in the
Daredevil series but what makes this
exciting is what this all could be
setting up for the future of not only
the street level Avengers team but the
future of Spider-Man it's looking like
Spider-Man is being set up to go against
one of the most iconic Spider-Man
villains there is and that is Kingpin
now concerning the street level Avengers
team we can already see how that's being
set up in the MCU we have Spider-Man of
course Daredevil and it looks like
She-Hulk is going to be joining that
roster as well and of course every
Avengers team needs a villain and it's
looking like that ultimate big bad
villain of the street level Avengers is
going to be Kingpin and he's going to be
popping up in multiple different
projects he was kind of the main villain
of Hawkeye although they didn't reveal
him until the very final episodes but if
you think he's dead because Echo shot
him in the face well think again he's
not this has already been confirmed by
Marvel Studios we know that Kingpin is
going to be the villain of the echo
series and also the Daredevil series as
well and it's looking like he could even
go on to become the villain of
Spider-Man 4. now please keep in mind
this is not confirmed by Marvel Studios
but it is seemingly what they are
hinting at Kingpin has already been
confirmed to be the villain of three
different Series so far Hawkeye Echo and
Daredevil all of these are street level
projects and kingpins clearly here for
the long run it doesn't seem like
they're going to get rid of him anytime
soon but keep in mind at the end of
Spider-Man no way home we saw Peter
Parker basically get an entirely new
life he kind of downgraded a bit of
course nobody knows that Peter Parker a
Spider-Man Actually nobody really knows
who Peter Parker is at all so no more
friends and no more Avengers at least
not for a little bit also keep in mind
the Avengers probably still remember
Spider-Man it's just Peter Parker who
they probably don't know but even then
Kevin feige has confirmed there is no
Avengers team right now they don't
really exist so the types of crime and
the villains that Spider-Man is going to
fight are going to to be different
they're not going to be on such a huge
scale anymore they're not going to be
these Cosmic threats like Thanos or
these other multiversal threats they're
going to be threats that are right there
on the street level in New York and
that's where Kingpin comes in and that's
where the street level Avengers team
comes in we'll talk about that in just a
bit but first a big thank you to Mint
mobile for sponsoring this video most
people know about mint mobile because of
Ryan Reynolds but most people don't know
about mint Mobile's amazing quality now
I live in the mountains and service
isn't too good however mint mobile sent
me a free plan and I get better service
with their plan than I do with my other
provider but what's crazy is their plan
is so much cheaper mint mobile offers
Wireless for just 15 bucks a month they
give you the best rate whether you're
buying for one or a family and at mint
mobile families start at only two lines
all plans come with unlimited talk and
text plus high-speed data delivered on
the nation's largest 5G Network plus
mint Mobile's Modern Family Plan lets
you mix and match data plan so everyone
gets the amount of data that's right for
them and you can use your own phone and
keep your same number and contacts so to
get your new Wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month including the Modern
Family Plan go to mintmobile.com Cosmic
that's mintmobile.com Cosmic cut your
wireless build down to 15 bucks a month
at mintmobile.com Cosmic so Kevin feige
the president of Marvel Studios made it
very clear that the MCU was essentially
going to be split into different groups
we have the cosmic side which is going
to be the Guardians of the Galaxy it's
going to be the Marvels and hopefully
the Silver Surfer because recently
there's been a report that a Silver
Surfer solo project is in the works then
we have the supernatural side now
werewolf by Knight set that up along
with Moon Knight and of course we have
blade coming when they finally get
everything kind of settled over there
with that project and then of course we
have the street level and this is
awesome because we're going to see an
entirely different side of Spider-Man
that we haven't really seen too much of
in the MCU one thing I'm actually really
excited about and seeing in Spider-Man 4
is Spider-Man slash Peter Parker be on
his own so far in the MCU he's always
been under the wing of somebody yeah he
was kind of on his own and homecoming at
the end there when he fought against
vulture but for most of that movie he
had help from Stark and far from home he
still had a lot of Technology helping
him out plus he had happy as well and a
fake Nick Fury who was really Talos and
then of course in Spider-Man no way home
he had the other two Peter Parkers and
of course doctor strange and we can't
forget about Ned and MJ but now he
literally has nobody so everything is
going to be made by him his suit which
we saw at the end of Spider-Man no way
home made by him and hopefully we'll see
other iterations of his suit and his own
Technology Incorporated into these suits
I'm personally really looking forward to
seeing more of Peter's genius side in
the MCU now this might actually make
Spider-Man 4 a bit darker than we've
previously seen Spider-Man although
Spider-Man no way home there were some
pretty dark Parts but if Kingpin truly
is going to be the main villain and it
is looking that way and Daredevil could
potentially join him while Kingpin and
Daredevil are two characters who are
pretty brutal so the fighting that we
could be seeing in Spider-Man 4 could be
just on another level hopefully it's
more along the lines of what we got when
Spider-Man fought the Green Goblin in no
way home at the end of no way home we
saw that Peter was using an old police
radio to locate crime street level crime
and eventually I'm assuming that
everything's going to add up and point
towards Kingpin being the head of a huge
criminal organization so naturally to
stop a lot of the organized crime in New
York City Spider-Man is going to want to
go to the top and stop them there that's
going to be Kingpin and this will most
likely fall in line with the stories
that are already going to be told
through the echo series and the
Daredevil Series so all of these things
combined are most likely going to be the
main plot for Spider-Man 4 which I'm all
here for I would really love to see
Spider-Man go up against Kingpin now for
those who wanted the Venom symbiote
trust me I do too but if Tom Holland is
returning for another Trilogy it might
be best to start off on the street level
and watch Peter Parker as he grows and
as I mentioned in the beginning rumor
has it that Spider-Man is going to get
the Venom symbiote during Secret Wars or
possibly even right before it maybe at
the end of Spider-Man 4. it could be its
post-credits scene from here in secret
Wars he could use the powers that the
Symbiote would give him to fight this
multiversal battle this would no doubt
give him a lot more strength and other
powers that he could definitely use to
fight Kang or Doctor Doom or whoever's
going to be the big bad of Secret Wars
then in the next film Spider-Man 5 he
could deal with the repercussions of
having the Venom symbiote attached to
him this could also lead to a more comic
accurate Venom we could have the comic
accuracy of Spider-Man getting the black
symbiote suit for the first time in
secret Wars then he could reject the
suit reject the Symbiote and it could go
on to find Eddie Brock and from here we
could have the classic Venom hates
Spider-Man and wants revenge on him that
classic storyline in the MCU I think
that would be absolutely amazing so
right now the future of Spider-Man is
looking pretty dang good we'll have
Spider-Man 4 then we'll have Avengers
the King Dynasty which he'll most likely
show up in and then of course Secret
Wars and from there of course we'll get
Spider-Man 5 and hopefully 6. so let me
know what you think about this in the
comments down below is this what you
would like to see in Spider-Man 4 be
sure to let me know also don't forget to
subscribe and like the video so you
don't miss out on any of the latest news
for live updates you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof